commencer cette conférence de presse
soyez elle est bienvenus au Sénat du
très heureux avec mes collègues et au
nom de la délégation d'avoir adopté ce
matin le rapport sur la continuité
territoriale on a intitulé remédier au
manquement ou une continuité à la
hauteur d'un effort budgétaire que nous
souhaiterions tous mais je laisserai les
rapporteurs développés les différents
aspects de ce rapport s'il fallait que
je le résume très brièvement avant de
leur laisser la parole et de pouvoir
développer les différentes
recommandations qui ont été adoptées ce
matin je dirais qu'aujourd'hui la on
parle de discontinuité territoriale qui
est quasiment une réalité pour
l'ensemble des outre-mer et puis on se
rend compte au travers des auditions qui
ont été menées donc il y a quand même eu
38 auditions 51 heures 111 personnes
auditionnées de déplacements en
outre-mer pour prendre le pouls
également de la réalité de nos
territoires parce que depuis Paris c'est
facile de s'imaginer des choses et quand
on va toucher du doigt la réalité de ce
qu'est la continuité territoriale et y
compris dans nos territoires à
l'intérieur de nos territoires je pense
que c'est un exercice qui s'imp et le
Sénat est évidemment et la délégation en
l'occurrence toujours
porteuse de ce genre d'initiative le
deuxième grand axe finalement de ce
rapport j'ai presque envie de dire que
la politique de continuité aujourd'hui
c'est une espèce de cotère sur une jambe
de bois donc on se rend bien compte et
la critique qui est opérée au travers de
ce rapport avec une critique objective
sur les dispositifs qui sont mis en
place et qui d'ailleurs justifient cette
troisième point du rapport
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement envisage
une refonte de la Dom en tout cas on
espère et le vous verrez que les
rapporteurs le diront mieux que moi un
élargissement de la donne qui est pour
nous le bras armé en outre-mer de la
politique de l'État au titre de la
continuité territoriale et grâce au
titre effectivement il y a un certain
nombre de préconisations de constats qui
ont été opérés là aussi pour objectif un
peu les choses la vocation de la
délégation au travers des douze
recommandations si bien évidemment
d'alimenter le débat national qui est en
cours sur le sujet d'être contributeur à
la réflexion aux côtés du gouvernement
et pas simplement un agitateur sur un
sujet dont on sait qu'il est prédom pour
dans nos territoires donc vraiment on
s'est positionné comme la tradition du
Sénat nous l'impose continuellement
c'est vraiment dans une offre de service
dans les réflexions du gouvernement je
pense que d'ailleurs le gouvernement un
peu anticipé vraisemblablement la sortie
de ce rapport puisque ça n'aurait
échappé à personne que il y a quelques
jours maintenant une augmentation du
dispositif individuel a été annoncé par
le gouvernement vous verrez que pour la
délégation on envisage une vision un peu
plus globale quand même du dispositif et
pas simplement entre guillemets ce qu'on
pourrait considérer comme des mesurettes
voilà donc on est vraiment sur une
réforme qu'on pourrait dire systémique
pour reprendre certains termes que les
gens comprendront mieux au travers de
tous les dispositifs qui existent et
avec tous les partenaires qui peuvent
être sollicités je vais mettre en
laisser la parole de rapporteurs que le
danger remercie la qualité du travail et
de l'investissement vraiment Catherine
cancone et Guillaume Chevrollier qui ont
vraiment mené ce dossier avec avec
beaucoup de cœur beaucoup de panache et
on y apportant un regard objectif encore
une fois et vraiment dans une démarche
de proposition d'offre auprès des
réflexions qui sont en cours aujourd'hui
avec la volonté de pouvoir apporter une
réponse à nos concitoyens tout
simplement et t'apporter de faire en
sorte que cette continuité territoriale
ne soit pas vécue comme un handicap
structurel pour nos territoires mais bel
et bien comme un atout qui permet à nos
ultramarins de pouvoir venir dans
l'Hexagone et aux ultra marin d'hexagone
de pouvoir revenir sur leur territoire
dans les meilleures conditions et
j'inclus évidemment là-dedans tout le
volet étudiant je vais maintenant
laisser la parole aux deux rapporteurs
qui pourront évidemment répandre à
toutes vos questions qui j'en suis sûr
seront nourries au travers de dossier de
presse qui vous a été remis
en tant que sénateur de métropole ou de
l'Hexagone pour reprendre les formules
la formulation de ma collègue au
rapporteur j'étais
très intéressé par cette mission autour
de la continuité territoriale le sujet
de la mobilité il est au cœur des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens ou qui
se trouve qui soit en métropole ou en
outre-mer la mobilité que l'on doit
décarboner et les problèmes d'égalité
dans l'accès à la mobilité et ça on les
trouve en métropole entre des
territoires urbains qui sont des servis
et des territoires ruraux mais avec le
regard de du parlementaire de métropole
quand on voit la problématique de cette
mobilité dans les territoires
ultramarins elle se pose à un niveau qui
est bien différent c'est comme l'a dit
le président de la délégation c'est de
continuité est-ce qu'elle existe
vraiment et au travers des déplacements
des auditions on a pu mesurer à quel
point il y avait de fortes attentes
parce que cette continuité elle est elle
est sous plusieurs angles elle a la
continuité permettent la mobilité entre
des citoyens des territoires ultramarins
vers l'Hexagone c'est la mobilité aussi
des ultramarins dans leur territoire
lui-même et puis c'est cette possibilité
aussi de pouvoir avoir une mobilité vers
entre territoires
ultramarins donc c'est tous ces aspects
là que nous avons souhaité examiner au
travers de rapport d'information danse
pour établir un diagnostic objectif
faire le constat que il y a une
politique qui existe mais faire état de
ces lacunes faire état de la dégradation
d'ailleurs du montant budgétaire alloué
à ces politiques donc tout a été mis
dans ce rapport pour pour faire bouger
les lignes parce que on le voit les
fractures je le disais existent en
métropole les fractures territoriales
elles existent mais avec l'outre-mer
avec nos concitoyens à d'outre-mer il y
a vraiment un sentiment d'être pas
suffisamment pris en compte pour
permettre l'effectivité de cette
politique de continuité territoriale
donc je pense qu'un rapport comme le
nôtre qui avant même d'ailleurs d'être
communiqué fait déjà bouger les lignes
puisque le gouvernement a réagi il est
là pour alimenter le débat faire
progresser et faire bouger les lignes
budgétaires on y reviendra peut-être
dans le détail avec avec ma collègue
mais on fait un certain aussi après de
recommandations
d'orientation pour pour faire en sorte
que cette attente d'une réelle
continuité territoriale avec les
différentes déclinaisons que j'évoquais
vers l'Hexagone
intra territoire ultramarin et entre
territoires ultramarins soit effectif
dans les prochaines années alors le on
vous a remis un dossier de de presse je
peux commencer par par
évoquer un certain nombre de
recommandations mais je laisserai
Catherine Concorde
les développer également
on a aussi fait des des comparaisons
avec ce qui se fait dans d'autres
territoires européens en termes de
continuité on a mis aussi en discussion
des dispositifs de continuité qui
existent avec nos concitoyens de Corse
on met tout ça sur la place publique
après il y a des comparaisons qui
appellent à ce que les lignes bougent
mais comparaison n'est pas raison
mais une réalité c'est que le statu quo
n'est pas tenable en l'état et ce
rapport doit vraiment être un point de
départ il y a des lignes de force
extrêmement important à pointer c'est
parmi les recommandations qu'on met dans
le haut c'est l'instauration d'un d'un
tarif résident puisque
on le voit et dans le contexte où nous
nos territoires ultramarins ils ont
besoin d'une continuité avec des voix
aériennes et on le sait toutes les
compagnies aériennes tous les acteurs du
secteur ont été positionnés les prix des
billets d'avion n'ont pas vocation à
baisser dans les prochaines années pour
un certain nombre de raisons et pour
permettre la mobilité et bien avoir un
tarif résident qui qui permettent de
pallier à des volatilités de prix et
notamment la saisonnalité c'est un point
extrêmement important à prendre en
compte
un autre point aussi très fort qui
aurait des traductions budgétaires c'est
les plafonds de revenus
unanimantes ou les acteurs quel que soit
les territoires ultramarins
exprimé
le constat que le plafond de ressources
est bas et il limite les possibilités
pour un certain nombre de compatriotes
d'avoir accès aux dispositifs et donc ça
c'est c'est regrettable puisque vous le
savez ces politiques de continuité
territoriale c'est c'est le lien entre
la métropole et nos concitoyens des
différents territoires ultramarins pour
pour la formation professionnelle pour
pour la formation initiale la formation
professionnelle pour la mobilité
professionnelle et même également les
préoccupations autour de l'accès aux
soins et c'est là aussi en tant que
sénateur de métropole on sait au combien
la difficulté de l'accès aux soins et
les problématiques de mobilité se pose
également sur le territoire national
mais là encore une fois en termes de
dimension quand vous êtes en un
territoire ultramarin c'est encore plus
compliqué donc cet accès aux soins il y
a aussi le point sur la continuité
funéraire c'est dire aussi
l'exhaustivité du rapport que nous avons
produit en termes de diagnostic et de
préconisations donc au travers des
dispositions très désorientations qu'on
suggère bien sûr le président de la
délégation l'a évoqué il y a la place
c'est important de la DOM et une
réflexion qui est engagée la Dom de
ville 2024 et nous nos travaux sont là
pour nourrir le travail de la Dom 2024
pour aller vraiment au plus près
des attentes de nos compatriotes
ultramarins
et de faire en sorte que que cette
réforme
attendue on aille vers les souhaits de
nos populations dans la diversité des
situations
donc il y a ces traductions budgétaires
que on aura l'occasion de mettre dans le
débat budgétaire de du projet de loi de
finance et puis aussi des dispositions
autour du fret mais je vais laisser ma
collègue vous les exposez en indiquant
que c'était et je remercie en cela la
délégation pensez intéressant sur ce
type de sujet d'avoir le regard croisé
entre la sénatrice c'est d'ailleurs
l'essence même de la délégation des
Outre-mer d'avoir un des un binôme
paritaire avec un regard croisé
ultramarin et de métropole et pour nous
c'est d'ailleurs aussi un souhait que
j'ai exprimé dans les recommandations
c'est que on a les implantations de la
DOM sur le territoire métropolitain et
je souhaite qui est un investissement
plus important encore des collectivités
locales de métropole dans dans l'accueil
dans l'accompagnement sous toutes ses
formes des ultramarins qui viennent se
former qui viennent pour la formation
initiale ou formation professionnelle
pour vraiment faire vivre le lien entre
nos concitoyens
ultramarins et les et les métropolitains
pour une meilleure connaissance mutuelle
un accueil une prise en considération
parce que aussi cette continuité
territoriale vers les territoires
ultramarins elle est aussi de métropoles
vers
les territoires
ultramarins c'est aussi important de le
rappeler dans la relation qui mérite
d'être renforcée en tout cas je pense
que nos préconisations doivent aller
dans le sens de cette amélioration et de
cette continuité territoriale mais aussi
des liens qui doivent exister entre la
mét et les outre-mer merci de votre
attention et laisse la parole à
Catherine
je remercie mon collègue Guillaume
chevrolier qui vous a dit déjà un
certain nombre de choses sur ce rapport
mes premiers mots seront pour remercier
le président de la délégation mon cher
Stéphane antano qui a accepté avec son
équipe que je salue en particulier
Thierry Aaron qui nous a accompagné
pendant tout ce rapport pendant ces
trois mois extrêmement dense d'avoir
accepté cette proposition que j'ai faite
en décembre de mener une mission sur la
continuité territoriale et je te l'avoue
Président je pensais pas au moment où je
faisais cette proposition découvrir une
matière aussi dense
aussi sulfureuse aussi dramatique aussi
au vu de ce que nous avons vu quant aux
devoirs j'insiste aux devoir de l'État
et au droit des citoyens d'outre-mer
quand tu as la continuité territoriale
je ne pensais pas qu'on aurait trouvé la
un terreau aussi fertile en matière
d'iniquité
nous sommes français dans l'outre-mer
jusqu'à nouvel ordre nous sommes
français moi personnellement je ne suis
pas indépendantiste ni séparatiste ce
compagnonnage avec la France ne me pose
pas de problème dans la mesure où c'est
où il doit être un compagnonnage
mature adulte d'adultes adultes sans
esprit de paternalisme et de domination
mais aujourd'hui il est clair et on peut
le conclure qu'en matière de continuité
territoriale l'état n'accomplit pas à
son devoir comme l'État devrait mon
propos n'est pas un propos pour attaquer
l'état parce que j'aurais pu faire
l'historique de comment les choses ont
commencé comment certains présidents
taillé dans le dans le gras de ces
budgets dédiés à la continuité
territoriale je suis pas là pour faire
des procès on est là pour faire avancer
les choses et moi ma vie politique c'est
ainsi que j'envisage comment on peut à
l'endroit où nous nous trouvons en tant
que parlementaire et lu local à quelques
niveaux que ce soit porter notre pierre
à l'édifice et dire voilà nous sommes
les meilleurs spécialistes de nos
propres affaires donc comment on peut
vous dire voilà comment il faut faire
voilà comment il faudrait faire donc ce
rapport que nous livrons aujourd'hui est
une contribution essentielle
que nous allons offrir à l'état à
l'exécutif afin de corriger ce qui doit
être corrigé personnellement je suis une
adepte de l'équité vous voyez
normalement ça devrait être l'égalité
liberté égalité fraternité on le lit sur
tous les frontons des édifices publics
je demande l'équité parce que rien n'est
comparable en soi et on pourrait pas
comparer un aller-retour Paris -
Valenciennes avec un aller-retour Paris
Fort-de-France mais les principes
d'accompagnement des populations doivent
être respectées et doivent être à la
hauteur des engagements de l'État mais
également à la hauteur de la situation
respective de chaque département de
chaque région de chaque territoire de la
vie outre-mer c'est un principe que la
République doit observer dans toutes les
décisions et dans toutes les politiques
publiques qui doivent être menées et là
vous livrer quelques chiffres
accompagnement de l'État à la continuité
territoriale encore
257 euros par habitant et par an
accompagnement de l'État dans la peau
les populations de ladite outre-mer
dressez bien les oreilles 16 euros
16 euros donc tant mieux pour mes
amicaux je félicite ce travail d'à peu
près 50 ans puisque ce sont des
dispositifs qui datent de 76 ce travail
qui a été fait car certainement pris du
temps qui est monté progressivement mais
on voit bien que il y a un problème il y
a une différence et voyager pour les
gens qui sont dans nos pays ce n'est pas
luxe quand on voyage pour venir ici
c'est pas pour aller faire les soldes
c'est pas pour aller au Club Med de
Marseille ou de Nice on voyage souvent
pour des questions essentielles la santé
par exemple trouver un spécialiste
souvent ophtalmo caoutchouc etc sous nos
yeux relève de la gageure on vit dans
des déserts médicaux permanents ou même
les médecins généralistes manquent à
l'appel aujourd'hui et lorsque quelqu'un
doit se faire consulter ou passer un
examen un peu complexe genre IRM il doit
attendre ou partir
une consultation ophtalmo aujourd'hui le
délai est entre 8 et 12 mois donc quand
on souffre et bien on cassatiolir et on
part parce que à Paris j'ai fait
l'expérience en une semaine on peut
trouver un ophtalmo
partir c'est aussi étudier étudier parce
que on est des petits marchés vous le
savez on n'aura pas une offre complète
d'études on va pas toutes les écoles
d'ingénieurs on n'aura pas toutes les
écoles de Sciences Po et tout et tout ce
niveau d'études auquel doit aspirer
également nos populations c'est légitime
c'est l'ascension sociale on y a droit
aussi cet effort en matière de qualité
de l'offre de formation nia doit aussi
mais on peut pas tout faire sur place la
Martinique que je connais mieux c'est
350 000 habitants donc on ne peut pas
avoir une compétite de tout sur place
donc partir est nécessaire à partir elle
légitime et je rajouterais même que
partir est obligatoire
mais on a aussi les pays les plus
pauvres de France les niveaux de
personnes avec des revenus bas sont
multipliés par X
par X le taux de pauvreté était pas
autant chez nous les personnes qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
c'est plus de 30 % de la population
donc face à ce cette situation quand
quelqu'un est malade il doit pas partir
que son gamin doit partir faire des
études et tout il fait comment bien
lorsque un billet d'avion coûte 1500
euros pour un aller-retour
Fort-de-France Paris ce qui est le cas
en ce moment en classe économique ou pas
loin il y a des promos parfois on va
voir sur les sur les écrans un
aller-retour assassin et quel bon là
généralement on n'a pas mis les taxes et
généralement c'est une offre limitée
dans le temps il faut aller la saisir
très vite et très en amont du besoin de
voyager
et quand l'État même en ayant augmenté
il y a 15 jours suite au vote que nous
avons effectué au PLF au dernier PLF
descend dernier d'augmenter la dotation
de la Dom parce de 270 à 320 euros je
vous laisse imaginer le reste à changer
une famille lorsque les membres
d'iniquité qui me bouleverse énormément
et le mot est faible si ce plafond me
ressources ce plafond qu'on appelle le
quotient tout le monde connaît ça sur
votre feuille d'impôts il y a une
histoire de croustillant je suis pas
très bonne dans ces calculs là mais
enfin vous savez de quoi je parle le
plafond est à 11900 euros
annuel fait les comptes
autrement dit c'est une famille à 1000
euros moi même pas le SMIC autrement dit
un dispositif qui s'adresse
partiellement mais à des gens
extrêmement pauvres
ou va-t-on quand on sait en plus que
dans ces pays-là la matière alimentée
est supérieure de la matière alimentaire
par exemple et supérieur de 38% un
paquet de riz à Paris un paquet de riz
en Martinique ou 38 puis 138% plus cher
donc vous voyez bien qu'on est dans une
situation qui n'est pas acceptable la
fréquence de ces transports dans
d'autres et on va en parler rapidement
dans d'autres pays
y compris en France
le la fréquence n'est pas limitée
à Paris
là c'était individuelle qui concerne
l'aide à la continuité territoriale dit
à CT la formule la plus simple de la DOM
c'est une fois tous les trois ans révolu
autrement dit si vous êtes partir 2020
la prochaine fois vous partirez en 2024
voilà merci Monsieur d'avoir aussi les
sourcils vous avez tout traduit donc on
est on est dans un dans un dans un dans
une situation qui peut pas durer
qui n'est pas possible et je vous parle
même pas de la cité spécifique alors
c'est une invention qui a été rajoutée
il y a pas longtemps qui parle de
certainement de très bon esprit il y a
des sportifs qui doivent se déplacer
pensez bien que sur nos territoires
challenger entre entre nous-mêmes ça
finit par connaître ses limites nos
équipes gagnent elles gagnent des
compètes l'outre met en fourni des
champions olympiques des champions de
foot des champions
regarder l'excellent gardien de but
Meignan quand vous avez vu récemment
elle était un but et les images font le
tour du monde
vous avez vu donc il est
donc on a des sportifs et lorsque
j'entends le président du comité
olympique qui a été de dernier
auditionnés nous dire
le transport bloque tous tes sons du
sport
antio guyanair enfin ultramaret et un
problème il refuse des compétitions ils
sont obligés de refuser des stages
d'aller ailleurs se confronter à
d'autres équipes pour monter en
performance parce qu'entre nous-mêmes on
a vite fait le tour
quand il vous le dit le roi il devait
participer à une manifestation
importante pour préparer les Jeux
Olympiques à Paris il y a 15 jours il a
renoncé à son voyage parce qu'en classe
économique c'était 1400 euros
donc il y a vraiment un problème quant à
la continuité territoriale et très
franchement lorsque j'ai proposé cette
mission à la à la délégation je savais
qu'il y avait un problème j'entendais
les gens parler du billet d'avion qui
augmente et tout mais comme l'a dit le
président tout à l'heure on n'est pas là
pour se contenter de dire ça va pas en
tout cas c'est pas ma manière de faire
la politique je laisse ça au syndicat
nous je préfère qu'on soit davantage
dans la construction les les politiques
doivent porter leur contribution voir
quand ça va pas le constater et aller
plus loin et là on est allé plus loin et
là on a fait les constats que je viens
de vous dire nous nous sommes déplacés
nous sommes déplaçant en Guadeloupe et
nous sommes déplacés en Guyane alors la
Guyane
la Guyane il faut voir il faut le vivre
la discontinuité dans la discontinuité
autrement dit vous avez une commune
comme Marie pasoula qui est la plus
grande commune de France dans le pays le
département le plus grand de France la
Guyane c'est l'équivalent du Portugal en
surface et bien Marie pas sous la ou il
y a quand même 15000 personnes qui
vivent les discervies que par un avion
de 18 places qui pour un peu plus d'une
heure pour relier les deux et qu'il a
fait en fonction de la météo de comment
parce que les pistes ne sont pas
équipées il y a pas de radar dans
l'aéroport de réception à malipasoula
bon on y est allé vous êtes tous témoin
c'est plus une piste que l'aéroport plus
une piste d'aéroport non éclairée donc
il faut quitter marie-passoula dès 17h30
au plus tard sinon l'avion ne parle pas
le volume de l'avion n'est limité qu'à
1400 kg donc on pèse aussi bien les
passagers que le fait
et par moment c'est fret au passager
faut pas prendre les deux et là et bien
il faut payer des billets d'avion et là
alors qu'on est face à un problème
d'équipement il y a pas de route bon
tant mieux à la limite la maçonnerie
prisée au pays d'une route je dis
pourquoi pas une route ça ferait à peu
près 700 km il y a pas de route mais la
France devrait faire en tout cas le
constat d'une carence en matière
d'équipement pour dire nous prenons à
notre change le déplacement de ces
populations là même pas on laisse
l'essentiel de la charge à la
collectivité locale qui chaque année
doit faire un chèque de 10 millions
d'euros pour payer une DSP à transporter
et en Guyane et ainsi permettre aux
autochtones de voyager avec un tarif
réduit
compensé par la collectivité
l'état vient mettre un petit million
comme ça voilà très symboliquement
montant qui n'a pas été diminué
donc on est dans des situations qui sont
pas normal c'est pas le seul jouer
d'autres missions à te proposer
Président c'est pas les seuls mais en
tout cas on a la matière là pour
rectifier et raboter cette situation qui
n'est pas tenable alors bien sûr on va
entendre sur le billet d'avion on va
généralement rester à l'écume des
valeurs les billets sont chers les
compagnies et tout non les compagnies
elles sont pas fautives le billet
d'avion ils ont dit l'augmenter c'est
objectif quand vous avez un jet fuel qui
est multiplié par 3 vous connaissez
l'attention qu'il y a sur les idéaux
carbu au contenu de la de la guerre
compte tenu des tensions au Moyen-Orient
etc quand vous prenez triplement de
votre tonnes de jet fuel il faut bien
quelqu'un paye au bout
faut que quelqu'un paye au bout et en
même temps qu'augmente les hydrocarbures
ici on va faire voler l'avion on a pas
encore popularisé l'avion solaire
tout a augmenté les contrats de
maintenance augmentent bien sûr
automatiquement les pièces détachées
s'envolent c'est le cas pour les
véhicules aussi donc l'aviation se
retrouve avec des changes énormes et
aujourd'hui les compagnies qui nous
desserrent sont toutes en difficulté
donc si peut-être facile de tirer sur
l'ambulance en se disant allez
compagnies bon d'accord ça c'est le plus
simple mais c'est pas de leur faute oh
bien sûr il faut aller regarder de temps
en temps s'il y a pas une petite entente
pas aussi par là mais j'ai envie de dire
à la limite son presqueusables dans ce
de ce monde épitoyable il y a parfois
des systèmes dès qu'il faut trouver pour
survivre il y a les trois compagnies qui
desservent la Martinique et la
Guadeloupe aujourd'hui sont en
difficulté y compris la compagnie
nationale qui a 42 milliards de dettes
on sort du covid 2 ans d'avion à Théo
de solidarité et de l'éloignement tous
les pays d'outre-mer sont des îles sauf
la Guyane et à rapprocher les conditions
d'accès de la population au service
public de transport de formation de
santé de communication de celle de la
métropole en tenant compte de la
situation géographique économique et
sociale particulière à chaque outre-mer
bon le cadre est posé je suis presque
envie de dire on a même pas de loi à
faire pour une fois on va même pas
besoin de la loi donc là maintenant il
faut que l'État assume donc forcément il
y aura des incidences budgétaires comme
je vous ai dit mon propos n'est pas de
pointer le doigt c'est pas c'est pas mon
style en politique je préfère dans la
construction de dire qu'il y a une
carence là et un truc qui va pas alors
pas vu pas pris jusqu'à présent
et puis une fois qu'on commence à
gratter à entrer dedans on se rend
compte qu'il y a un problème mais bon on
a gratte si on est rentré dedans et
maintenant on vient on va livrer à au
plus haut lieu en plus haut lieu on
n'hésitera pas à aller voir le Père le
président de la République pour lui dire
c'est le président la l'état fait défaut
la solidarité de la nation n'est pas
n'est pas en œuvre il faut rectifier
alors forcément il y aura des incidences
budgétaires mais on est prêt à entendre
que ça peut monter progressivement on
n'est pas des inconscients mais il y a
déjà là pour le prochain PLF un il faut
important à faire et si l'état déjà
pouvait doubler le montant qui attribué
à la Dom c'est à dire passer au moins
100 millions et ben on aurait déjà un
effort objectif effectif et à minimum
pour pouvoir contrecarrer laisser 10
millions d'euros sur le dos de la
collectivité de Guyane par exemple en
lui donnant un petit million comme ça la
Manche pour compenser cette éloignement
c'est injuste
c'est totalement injuste
donc il faut que les tailles au moins
50% augmentent sa part donc les
préconisations étaient écrites on a
quand même fait un travail important on
vous a rappelé les chiffres près de 40
auditions plus d'une centaine de
personnes vues on a vu des choses
incroyables parfois inhumaines moi
quelque chose qui m'a choqué entre
maligalante et la Guadeloupe marie à une
heure de bateau de la Guadeloupe là
encore c'est la collectivité de
Guadeloupe qui assume cette double
insularité n'est-ce pas ma collègue
victoire jasmin guadeloupéenne est là et
bien vous savez lorsque quelqu'un sort
de ma ligament il va pas ils ont fait
une chimio sur ce qu'on appelle le
continent c'est à dire la grande île de
la Guadeloupe et bien elle attend le
bateau jusqu'au soir elle part le matin
elle fait sa chimio ça dit une heure et
après les sous l'angare là bien chaude
la garde-bergevin attendre le prochain
bateau il y a pas de bateau à la pause
méridienne parce que économiquement ça
ne tient pas pour le transporter ok un
privé je comprends je comprends
mais en même temps se dit là il devrait
avoir pareil on relève l'état quand je
lui demande combien lui coûterait cet
aller-retour supplémentaire
c'est beaucoup pour le transporteur qui
joue avec des équilibres qui lui aussi
subit les augmentations des idées au
carburant mais attendez rajouter une
pause méridienne ne serait-ce que les
seins 5 jours 5 jours de la semaine à
2000 euros c'est pas ça qui va ruiner
les affaires français
donc on est dans on a tout écrit on a
tout dit et je ne peux pas m'empêcher
pour terminer de faire un parallèle avec
les autres pays qui ont est situé
une politique de continuité territoriale
figurez-vous que nous sommes pas les
seuls rupes à périphériques y a pas que
la France qui est des web l'espagna
aussi des wips et le Portugal a aussi
des ados
Canaries ce sont des rupes non
françaises espagnoles et portugaise mais
qui sont regroupés sous le sous le
générique de région ultra périphérique
telle que l'on entend
la Communauté européenne mais
là aussi des effets ont été faits
figurez-vous que l'Espagne qui est pas
plus riche que la France
la plus riche que la France on est tous
on sait tous les grandes difficultés
qu'a connu l'Espagne récemment c'est 800
millions de WoW qui sont mis à
disposition chaque année pour la
continuité territoriale dans le rue
avec une contribution sur les billets à
75%
. le Portugal fut le même effet les
efforts de l'Espagne des Canaries etc
ces 223 euros par habitant
en France allez on revient en France
allez me dire bon là c'est les espagnols
les portugais sont plus riches plus
riches que nous donc je suis pas sûr
mais bon
je reviens à la course
257 euros par habitant je vous rappelle
nous c'est 16
donc là où il y a une volonté et un
chemin ici la République veut vraiment
donner des signes importants à ces
populations dans beaucoup de domaines
qui constatent qui souffrent et qui voit
ses problèmes d'égalité qui gênaient en
pas mal de difficultés et bien il y a
des signaux à donner il y a des signaux
à donner parce qu'on rajoute de la
difficulté à la difficulté on rajoute de
la pauvreté à la pauvreté je connais des
gens qui payent leurs billets dix fois
pour aller se faire soigner
et comme parfois la personne est malade
elle est obligée d'emmener une deuxième
personne
parce qu'elle est malade va elle va se
faire soigner elle va avoir un
spécialiste elle peut pas y aller seul
le mari le conjoint un enfant se joint
donc c'est des gens qui sont dettes
énormément et qui en plus une voix
arrivée ici
tombe dans un autre univers immense foi
voilà c'est pas c'est pas leur univers
donc la Domme doit totalement penser à
sa réforme ne plus s'occuper de
formation comme maintenant c'est le cas
puisque la formation était rapatriée au
Pôle emploi et récupérer à la fois ces
budgets ces énergies pour s'occuper de
la continuité de ces populations voilà
donc c'est un c'est un rapport qui
arrive dans ce bon agenda la Dom est
uniforme nous annonce à grande en grande
pompe la Domme 2024 il y a de quoi faire
la dôme 2024 là et dès demain on va
commencer à rentrer en négociation
insister à dire ce qu'il y a lieu d'être
dit mais on peut pas continuer comme ça
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire pour
compléter ce que vous a dit alors dans
les documents vous avez toutes les
préconisations que l'on fait vous
pourrez les découvrir et je termine par
une une phrase d'aimer Césaire qui dit
tous les hommes ont des devoirs mais il
y en a qui ont plus de devoirs que
d'autres
voilà
donc on va passer si vous le voulez bien
aux questions aux questions-réponses au
moins celles que vous auriez déjà
simplement vous dire
en conclusion avant que les questions
puissent circuler dans la salle
qu'on ne se contentera pas au Sénat
d'une réponse qui consisterait à être
les crédits ne nous permettent pas de
faire bouger les dispositifs je pense
que vous avez compris que l'ambition que
c'est fixé le Sénat pose clairement la
question de la place des Outre-mer dans
la République il faut avoir à l'esprit
que la continuité territoriale c'est
quand même un facteur de cohésion
sociale pour nos territoires et c'est un
facteur d'attractivité mais qui devient
qui deviennent des handicaps structurels
pour tous nos territoires et en réalité
ça pose clairement une question
philosophique et de choix politiques que
le gouvernement doit faire quel que soit
sa couleur politique d'ailleurs on est
là vraiment sur une approche
transpartisane et Guillaume Chevrier l'a
rappelé tout à l'heure la question de la
mobilité est une question fondamentale
donc autrement dit on pense aujourd'hui
et je sais que le ministre Arago est
sensible aux travaux du Sénat puisqu'il
a reçu les rapporteurs sur le dernier
rapport sur la gestion des déchets en
outre-mer et je ne doute pas je ne doute
pas à tout le moins ils seront également
intéressés à avoir les réflexions la
délégation et puis comme l'a dit
Catherine Concorde si il faut aller
toucher le président de la République
qui
idéal on évoquait notamment et vous le
voyez en plus il faut quand même le
préciser c'est pas simplement une
demande des ultramarins puisqu'on
précise dans le rapport dans notre
préconisations qu'on aimerait également
que des hexagonaux des étudiants qui
voudraient venir faire des stages dans
nos territoires puis c'est également
bénéficier de cette continuité a été
territoriale parce qu'ils n'ont pas plus
les moyens que nous autres à marins qui
souhaitent partir dans les agones faire
des stages donc on est vraiment là sur
une politique complètement transversale
et j'ai presque envie de dire
universaliste et que donc c'est bien
dans cet esprit que s'inscrit le rapport
maintenant je vous propose de pouvoir
poser toutes les questions
supplémentaires vous voudriez poser à ce
stade vous aurez évidemment le temps de
fouiller ce rapport qui est qui est
assez généreux en terme de proposition
et puis de donner techniques puisqu'il a
été quand même très nourri au travers
des auditions et vous pourrez évidemment
revenir vers les rapporteurs ou la
délégation pour des compléments
d'information mais déjà à ce stade
la parole peut circuler et je pense
qu'on a déjà une première question
d'autres mer 360 sur le périmètre donc
on est d'accord c'est les drums est-ce
que vous avez pu interroger des
représentants des comes des
collectivités qui je crois en leur
propre dispositifs de continuité
territorial est-ce qu'elle rencontre
aussi les mêmes problèmes les mêmes
problématiques j'imagine que oui mais je
vais juste répondre pour les rapporteurs
cette fois-ci puis après j'ai laisserais
répondre mais effectivement on a eu une
vision périphérique sur l'ensemble de
l'outre-mer voilà on n'a pas vos on est
on n'est pas dans cette logique de dire
en quand une collectivité à une
compétence on ne va pas la visiter voilà
on a vraiment un regard transversal
parce qu'on se dit que on l'a vu
d'ailleurs sur la crise sanitaire si je
peux me permettre un parallèle que
l'État est allé parfois dans certains
territoires au-delà de ce que la
répartition des compétences lui imposait
et on imagine que sur certains
dispositifs comme la continuité avec la
mère patrie on pense que cette question
peut être interrogée et donc on est allé
questionner effectivement l'ensemble des
collectivités et le constat qui est
opéré ici je pense pouvoir dire sous le
contrôle des rapporteurs qui les valable
pour tout nos territoires à des échelles
différentes mais ils valent pour tous
les territoires d'heures les 12
préconisations que vous voyez là elles
peuvent je pense une extension
s'appliquées à chacun de nos territoires
en tout cas elle trouveront un intérêt
dans chacun de nos territoires ce qui
veut dire que on est vraiment là sur une
vision périphérique et universelle du
dispositif tel que tel qu'on pourrait
l'imaginer dans la République qui est
celle de la République française
bonjour Nathalie Guibert pour le monde
j'avais une question sur ce que vous
évoquez page 38 sur la
l'enquête de l'Autorité de la
concurrence
elle a récemment publié
un avis est-ce que on parle de la même
chose
ou pas qui elle a récemment dénoncé une
entente entre les compagnies aériennes
donc est-ce que on parle bien du même
avis parce que vous dites que c'est elle
vient d'ouvrir une enquête ou est-ce que
c'est autre chose et est-ce que vous
avez senti dans les auditions que ces
questions d'entente
peuvent vont plus loin que ces liaisons
internes
Caraïbes des territoires ultramarins
est-ce qu'il y a des est-ce que il y a
des soupçons ou des besoins
d'investigation complémentaires à votre
sens et l'autre question que je voulais
vous poser c'était sur le la petite
mesure qui a annoncé le ministre
récemment justement sur les les
du modeste pour augmenter l'aide au
transport
est-ce qu'on sait est-ce qu'on sait
combien de personnes ça va combien de
personnes ça va bénéficier
sachant que j'imagine que sauf
effectivement nécessité absolue ce sont
précisément pas les plus modestes qui
qui prennent l'avion donc j'imagine sauf
des cas effectivement de santé ou de
décès donc on parle vraiment d'une
petite mesurette très petite mesurée a
priori ce qui a été annoncé récemment
je vais répondre sur
la qualification de mesurettes et puis
je laisserai les rapporteurs répondre
sur les autres questions
on voudrait pas rentrer dans une espèce
d'affrontement avec le gouvernement sur
sur ce dossier mais c'est vrai que c'est
un nom ça quelques jours du de la
restitution et qui coïncide quasiment à
l'audition par nos rapports du ministère
d'outre-mer peu interroger ou de la
au-delà de ça si vous voulez nous on a
quand même l'ambition au travers de ce
rapport d'avoir une vision qui est quand
même bien plus large que simplement une
vision paramétrique et je pense qu'on
est vraiment là sur une approche
systémique c'est que le gouvernement
doit réinterroger en profondeur et
d'ailleurs les travaux qui sont menés
par la Dom actuellement d'ailleurs dans
l'audition est disponible sur le site du
Sénat démontre aussi la qualité de la
réflexion des gens qui sont dans la DOM
et qui ont envie de faire bouger les
choses mais on voit tout de suite qui
sont très vite contraints et nous ce
qu'on aimerait c'est pouvoir ouvrir le
champ des possibles et donc ne pas avoir
des espèces d'effets d'annonce mesurées
entre guillemets qui viendrait peut-être
créer plus de frustration que de
n'importe quel réponses à nos à nos
concitoyens je vais peut-être maintenant
laisser le soin au rapport de répondre
aux autres questions sur l'autorité de
la concurrence notamment et puis les
entendre mais simplement pour vous dire
déjà sur le volet entente on n'est pas
là pour incriminer qui que ce soit la
délégation c'est l'intérieur ça n'est
pas une commission d'enquête on ne
dispose pas d'éléments d'information qui
nous permettent de dire qu'il y a des
ententes illicites ou autres simplement
on peut se poser certains membres de
questions parce que tout simplement le
monde économique parfois pousse certains
acteurs à certaines à certaines ententes
entre guillemets et je suis très prudent
quand je le dis mais je laisserai quand
une grand-comte préciser les choses oui
Président c'est cette question donc tu
as tout dit de toute façon c'est une
enquête donc on n'a pas les conclusions
et puis ça faisait pas partie du
périmètre de nos investigations et comme
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire tout à
l'heure la situation est parfois
tellement compliquée que parfois on peut
comprendre que chaque soci ouvert chacun
on regarde l'autre parce que c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué y compris dans
le régional c'est très compliqué donc
c'est pas du tout notre périmètre et
pour l'instant ils ont parlé d'une
enquête donc on attend les éventuels
conclusions mais j'ai presque envie de
dire ça ne regarde pas la deuxième
question qui
les mesures mais je serai dans le même
temps que le Président on n'est pas là
pour jauger s'ils ont rajouté 30 euros
40 euros je vous avoue je sais même plus
combien ils ont rajouté parce que pour
moi c'est pas ça à l'époque on est sur
le principe on est sur l'écosystème le
système mis en place pour assurer la la
continuité territoriale on est vraiment
sur une la philosophie de devoir qui due
à l'état qui n'est pas accompli à ce
jour comme ça devrait et on n'est pas là
pour passer l'État à la moulinette et
puis leur dire vous avez tous les
gouvernements qui ont précédé ont commis
des fautes dans la continuité
territoriale je peux vous dire que c'est
pas l'actuel je suis j'essaie toujours
d'être juste même quand je suis pas du
même mot politique c'est pas l'actuel
qui a commis le plus de fautes en la
matière capucera beauté les moyens donc
ça c'est le passé on referme la
parenthèse on voit pas les cartes et on
se dit ils se sont bien rendu compte
qu'il y a un problème puisque on a
ouvert la réforme de la Dom on annonce
la dame dans quelques mois donc on est
dans le bon tempo et on espère en tout
cas en tout cas c'est l'esprit de notre
rapport que les manquement que nous
avons soulevés qui sont quand même
énorme qui sont évidents qui sont
inacceptables devront être corrigés dans
cette nouvelle formule de la DOM et
d'une politique beaucoup plus large et
la continuité territoriale il y a un
comité interministériel outre-mer qui
est prévu en mai des travaux sont déjà
en cours et on espère que là aussi il y
aura des annonces faites sur la
continuité territoriale quant à
l'engagement de l'État et bien sûr de
manière corrélée l'engagement budgétaire
le ne va pas sans l'autre mais on est
avant tout chez le principe nos
populations on doit à une équité mieux
exprimer en matière de continuité
territoriale mais il faut le faire comme
je m'adire dans mon pays en créole
s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
vous disiez que votre ça fait un peu
suite à la première question vous disiez
que votre vision de la continuité
territoriale était universelle à
l'Outre-mer j'ai pas eu le temps de
regarder mais est-ce que vous pouvez
déjà nous dire s'il y a des
préconisations pour les sujets de
continuité territoriale à Tahiti puisque
c'est immense ils ont un sujet aussi de
territorial oh pardon de continuité
territoriale intérieure est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous pouvez dire à ces
gens-là que qu'il y a des choses qui
vont s'améliorer ou pas
oui comme on l'a indiqué en introduction
on a auditionné tous les territoires
ultramarins donc dans le rapport vous
verrez c'est un diagnostic objectif et
avec des préconisations des propositions
qui qui concerneront l'ensemble des
territoires vous évoquiez
un territoire qui est impacté par Triple
insularité voire davantage donc
effectivement on aura des des
propositions il y aura des déclinaisons
qu'on souhaite très très concrète pour
pour ce territoire là
et autres précisions également mais ça
rejoint ce que vient de dire mon
collègue Guillaume chevrolier vous
verrez d'ailleurs à la fin du rapport
dans le cadre du suivi des rapports des
travaux du Sénat de manière générale
l'identification des acteurs en charge
ou identifiés par les rapporteurs comme
mon responsabilité sur les
préconisations qui ont été faites le
calendrier et le type de mesure si c'est
de nature réglementaire législatif ou
autre ce qu'on voudrait éviter c'est
qu'effectivement d'aller prendre une
mesure particulière pour un territoire
en particulier parce qu'on essaye
justement d'avoir une vision
universaliste parce qu'on pense
réellement et profondément comme l'a dit
Guillaume Chevrollier que le constat
objectif qu'on a fait pour les uns est
valable pour les autres après les
échelles et les réalités de chacun des
territoires va évidemment amener à
calibrer les dispositifs mais il y a
aucune raison qui soit en dehors des
dispositifs tels qu'on les a constatés
évidemment droit à la même continuité
avec des difficultés accrues en termes
de distance et de déclatement complet
des îles bien évidemment
jusqu'au préciser que nous avons
auditionné tous les bassins
atlantiques Pacifique
Océan Indien on a vu tout le monde de la
réunion à la Nouvelle-Calédonie à
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon en passant par
la Polynésie on a vu tout le monde et la
Polynésie c'est du gigantisme en matière
de déplacement de besoin de déplacement
plusieurs dizaines d'aéroports
continuité en Polynésie donc bienvenue à
notre collègue ancien ministre Victor et
luel qui a bien connu ses cassures de
continuité territoriale
imaginez que puisse faire monter les
contributions de l'État 50% par exemple
dans les DSP comment la suite en Guyane
et bien la Polynésie pouvant bénéficier
également mais il faut que l'État montre
cette monte cette responsabilité et ce
devoir on vient on va les pays mais on a
consulté tout le monde et vous verrez
dans le rapport
notre premier audition ça a été la
course parce que c'était quand même
assez monumental par exemple mais après
on a vu tout le monde tout le monde tout
est déjà assez local et national
Polynésie Nouvelle-Calédonie Mayotte
réunion Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon les les
pays français d'Amérique tout le monde
je peux vous dire que les déplacements
étaient très nourris n'est-ce pas
Guillaume on a eu très peu de temps pour
dormir on a vu des dizaines de gens on a
écouté beaucoup mais il l'exemple des
Guyane qui
un modèle d'organisation
extraordinaire mais ces gens-là sont
presque des fous de maintenir ainsi et
lorsqu'on lance les DSP il y a personne
qui vient sur la DSP en dehors de parce
que les gens savent bien que c'est un
truc de c'est un truc de fou donc c'est
vrai que les patrons sont martiniquais
Guyane et guadeloupéenne donc ils ont
une fibre Patriot patriotique
nationaliste mais c'est une histoire de
fou et Oriane c'est ces gens là c'est
des tenir ça comme ça c'est vraiment
c'est pourquoi cette assassinat aux
règles sur les compagnies aériennes
quand on annonce le l'augmentation du
prix du billet et souvent très injuste
vraiment très injuste
pardon je vais j'avais une question qui
me que j'avais oublié dans le rapport
vous évoquez quelque chose qui est très
important qui est la notion de perte de
chance donc vous allez parler des
sportifs mais bon pour les étudiants
pour les malades et cetera
c'est quelque chose qui a une traduction
pénale aussi c'est cette affaire est-ce
que dans toutes les auditions
vous avez eu vous avez été informé de de
gens ou de personnes qui avaient de
groupes qui avaient commencé à se
bagarrer devant les tribunaux contre ces
cette perte de chance ou pas
enfin objectivement je ne pense pas je
pense que nos concitoyens vont tout si
on parle de la santé par exemple une
perte de chance en matière de santé
disons surtout envie de faire envie de
se faire soigner et de bien se faire
soigner et je ne crois pas que les gens
qui ont envie de bien se faire soigner
et qui doivent quitter leur territoire
parce que les plateaux techniques ne
permettent pas d'avoir la spécialité par
exemple et ont envie d'aller au pénal
d'abord avant de se faire soigner donc
non je pense que on est vraiment là sur
une une dimension éminemment politique
mais vous avez raison il y a
effectivement sur chacun de nos
territoires des pertes de champ son
matière de santé pour des gens qui n'ont
peut-être pas les moyens ou la capacité
parce que les dispositifs existants ne
sont peut-être pas suffisamment adaptés
je dis pas qu'il n'existe pas mais ils
à des gens qui n'ont pas les moyens de
partir dans l'Hexagone quand vous faites
traiter en oncologie comme pour
Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon à Rennes par
exemple même avec l'accompagnement de la
Caisse de Prévoyance Sociale peut-être
qu'il y a des personnes qui n'ont pas
les moyens d'avancer les frais peut-être
que le dispositifs sont pas tout à fait
adaptés peut-être que les plafonds de
ressources doit permettre pas non plus
telles qu'ils sont conçus aujourd'hui et
c'est une des préconisations
toucher d'autres dispositifs d'aide donc
mais oui effectivement on pense qu'il y
a des pertes de chances de manière
générale de toute façon il suffit de
regarder quand même la photographie de
l'état de santé en outre-mer de manière
globale pour voir quand même qu'il y a
un véritable sujet sur nos territoires
c'est aussi un étudiant c'est aussi un
étudiant effectivement et c'est aussi
pour ça que dans la dans le rapport on
préconise de muscler le rapport du moins
le passeport mobilité pour les études
parce qu'on considère effectivement que
les ions mais vous voyez on revisite
vraiment l'ensemble des dispositifs
existants parce qu'on considère que
justement le caractère universel de
cette approche doit nous permettre de
toucher l'ensemble des publics concernés
certaines très bien été dit tout à
l'heure par des rapports
c'est une fois par an c'est un
aller-retour un gars mec à 17 ans qui a
réussi au bac et qui part pour la
première fois en France c'est un autre
monde c'est un autre univers et partir
en septembre il ne pourra revenir en
juin et il se retrouve parfois passer
Noël seul dans le foie impossibilité de
rejoindre sa famille ou que sa famille
vienne nous rejoindre contrairement à un
étudiant qui est dans l'Hexagone et qui
pourra prendre un train pour retourner
dans dans sa ville natale et vous avez
des jeunes qui passent très mal ce
moment de solitude etc on a des
tentatives de suicide on a des abandons
d'études on a de vraies pertes de
chances
parler tout à l'heure de la Polynésie
monsieur simplement juste pour
rappelez-vous le verrez au travers du
rapport mais à la préconisation numéro 5
notamment il est prévu par exemple une
aide additionnelle spécifique de
continuité lorsque le trajet pour
rejoindre l'aéroport international je
pense que vous voyez à qui je fais
allusion de départ depuis son domicile
nécessite de prendre un avion ou un
bateau voilà donc c'est typiquement en
fait l'adaptation est on pense que c'est
valable à Polynésie et pas que la
Polynésie vraisemblablement mais en tout
cas pour la Polynésie c'est encore plus
vrai que pour certains territoires voilà
c'est typiquement le type de dispositif
qu'on n'a pas appelé polynésien mais je
pense que vous voyez tout de suite à qui
peut s'appliquer
je reviens sur la question des
compagnies aériennes et du coup qu'elle
doit
supporter récemment les compagnies
ultra-marines se sont un peu mis
ensemble pour dénoncer les prix
opérés par la Sarah ce que c'est dans le
cadre du rapport quelque chose que vous
avez pu voir est-ce que vous avez pu
auditionner les raffineurs
voilà Sarah longuement en Guadeloupe on
a pu longuement les écouter
le dernier jour de notre mission
Guadeloupe
l'état imposé
la taxe jet fioul
tu es obligé d'arrêter également à la
revente donc pour éviter que ne soit
supporté uniquement par les
automobilistes l'augmentation du fioul
il y a une espèce de piréquation foncée
qui a été imposée au monde de l'aviation
et qui est donc hyper cultive par les
saga sur sur les compagnies aériennes
alors effectivement ils ont
recours qui me semble légitime bon après
il faut voir si tout cela illégal auprès
des juridictions concernées
mais c'est une réalité parce que sinon
l'augmentation à la pompe pour
l'automobile Islanda ont été beaucoup
plus fortes donc on a fait porter par le
monde de l'aviation
voilà et même chose la Sarah qui raffine
pour la Guadeloupe la Martinique et la
Guyane est un petit modèle
d'industrie ça reste quand même la plus
petite raffinerie de France avec des
exigences en matière d'investissement
des exigences techniques qui sont
imposées aussi par des normes
européennes et c'est tant mieux c'est
vaisseaux le type de de carburant livrés
qui doit correspondre à des normes
hautement
qualifiés pour l'environnement mais ça
reste des petits modèles qui supportent
des investissements très importants et
qui forcément sortent un prix au litre
qui est important même si chez nous les
mangent sont maîtrisés imposées à la
Sarra il est pris ce sont les seuls prix
administrés chez nous c'est le prix de
des carburants et du gaz sont des prix
administrés c'est le préfet qui sont en
réalité tous les mois pour dire qu'elle
sera le prix du litre de gazoil des sens
ou de la bonbonne de gaz
c'est pas le cas pour les filles
arrêter cette conférence de presse
mettante en tout cas je vous remercie
beaucoup de votre présence et n'hésitez
pas évidemment sur la base de documents
qui vous a été remis à revenir vers les
rapporteurs et la délégation on fera un
plaisir de d'apporter les éléments
complémentaires merci et bonne fin de
journée à toutes et à tous